greetings to all if I were there with
you this is what I'd look like roughly
podium stage and lighting depending but
enough about me meet Jane no Jane is not
her real name nor is she in very good
shape but she is after all 400 years old
she probably looked like this in her
lifetime just before she died in the
struggling English colony at jamestown
virginia in the terrible winter of 1609
to 1610 known as the starving time jane
may indeed have succumbed from lack of
food and then she became food the
archaeologist who excavated her remains
in 2013 immediately noted that she had
been cannibalized after death the
cannibals meaning Jane's fellow
colonists had dug her up to feed
themselves they hacked open her skull to
get her brain sliced off parts of her
face and then we buried her so much for
early American food being a quaint ye
oldie topic many scholars had dismissed
eyewitness accounts of survival
cannibalism at Jamestown as propaganda
directed against the Virginia Company of
London but Jane's remains corroborate
the colonial rumors her scarred skull is
an excellent reminder of the materiality
of colonial America's past indeed the
presence or absence of food in the
colonies and then later in the United
States has been a critical reality at
all points in our history and yet who it
has taken a surprisingly long period of
time for the history of food to acquire
an important place within the profession
of academic historians there are three
reasons for this first historians have
been concerned if not panicked to avoid
the label of material determinism
culture ideas conscious actions and
every other kind of deliberative human
motivation and action have instead been
conceived as the main drivers of history
within my own original field of early
American history events were supposed to
have ideological origins not Material
ones that preference conditioned how
historians decided what topics to look
at and how and food was rarely in the
picture second many studies of American
food have actually been examinations of
culinary history the high end of the
field the analysis of cuisine
restaurants and luxury consumption this
struck many scholars as epiphone aminul
if not frivolous it's a widespread joke
among food historians that the only
subfield that seemed to be more
frivolous than food history was the
history of fashion oh but it's only a
coincidence that both subfields food and
fashion have had strong intersections
with the fields of women's history and
Gender Studies third there was an
equally strong prejudice that America
was the land of plenty that food history
cannot really be very illuminating
because food was never a significant
problem in American history what then
could it possibly reveal well right now
all three of these old ideas are
dissolving faster than a cookie dunked
in milk and it's about time historians
are finally ready to admit that America
had material as well as ideological
origins there is at last acceptance that
food history is more than culinary
history though also new defense of
cuisine is far from Phyllis itself a
powerful analytic tool for culture class
and gender finally it's no longer
tenable to believe that America has
always been a land of plenty even when
things were better than at Jamestown
during the starving time many people
went hungry in the past and even when
there were conditions of plenty it's
always worth asking plenty for whom let
me wrap up with some indications of how
and where I pursue this new line of
inquiry that food is one of our best
indicators of America's material origins
I do this in my own research this past
fall I published an essay food and the
material origins of early America in a
volume of essays that I co-edited with
two colleagues the volume is called food
and time and place the american
historical association Companion to food
history and i have examined the scarcity
related history of food in a book I am
co-authoring the new worlds of Thomas
Robert Malthus in which Alison bashford
and I argue that the new worlds of the
Americas australia and pacific islands
were central evidence for and indeed
constitutive of malthus's notorious
theory that humans could be produced
faster than food could be produced for
them I'm also a member of the Harvard
initiative on the science of the human
led by my colleague Michael McCormack
which unites questions and techniques
from the sciences and Humanities in
order to re-examine the human record and
this project very much includes the
history of food I'm delighted that among
my many wonderful graduate students
several are pursuing topics and food
history these are their names and topics
and I will pause now to let you read
through them getting a full sense really
of what food history is and can do in
the work of the rising generation I'm
also advising two new journals in food
history these are global food history of
which I'm a founding board member and
the Graduate journal of food studies for
which I'm a faculty advisor finally I
teach food history to undergraduates I
do this in Harvard's a general education
program in the category of United States
in the world and the course is called
American food a global history this is a
big subject that I have defined
according to ideas of scarcity and
abundance but next year's iteration come
spring will also emphasize a question of
how did the pass taste to get to the
bottom of that students in the class
will enjoy or maybe endure food samples
as well as non food samples meaning the
experience of hunger here's a possible
menu for you to save her I'm just
kidding about the human flesh we won't
really be eating that pretty much
everything else though feel free to drop
by